here we are now thirty kilometers out of
Madrid and I was wandering by adam lo
chose this place as a meeting point
until i saw the church because this was
a topic on euro max two years ago and it
has an incredible story
and that story is why as British expat
Adam Lowe's favorite place known as the
Cathedral it's almost entirely the work
of one man 88 year old justo Gallego has
been building the church on his own land
for over 50 years the devout Catholics
started building it in 1961 now it
towers 30 metres above the ground
what meaning has this place to you well
for me I remember first coming here
about 15 years ago when who stood been
building it for about 30 years and to
find somebody who was doing what they
love just building something with their
own hands with no political support no
support from the church no money just
doing what you want to do and whenever
I'm depressed
justo is my inspiration I come here and
you look at this and you think it's
really possible to make a difference as
for Madrid itself 3.3 million people
live here in the Spanish capital that
makes it the third largest city in the
European Union after London and Berlin
we met Adam Lowe once before four years
ago at his company [ __ ] doom auntie
together we take a look at the show we
made back then at the time Adam gave us
an insight into how he reproduces works
of art orders can come in from
governments museums or foundations the
copies require great skill and plenty of
high-tech equipment
how did fractal art a change in the last
four years I apart from the fact that I
think it's just grown and grown and
grown that we've developed more and more
of our own technologies I think it's
building this bridge between how new
technologies can serve and benefit both
historical applications and creative
applications that I think has really
come into focus now the company has
moved on from reproducing old
masterpieces to creating its own like
this world map and relief which will
eventually be as big as a soccer field
another development is his fiefdom
foundation which provides museums around
the world with a chance to preserve
their works of art with 3d scanners
atoms scanning one of his own works
right now a copy of a painting by the
Italian Baroque artist Caravaggio
I'd have learned his craft when he was
studying here in Madrid among other
places he later returned to the city and
has lived here ever since Madrid has
more than just a lively art scene though
the southern European lifestyle is in
full swing at places like this san
miguel market hall
just a few steps away a typical Spanish
souvenir is on sale a handmade wooden
fan with a traditional popular design
Madrid is also home of the Prado which
is one of the most famous art museums in
the world but Adams more interested in
another cultural center the casa
Incendia showcases works from ten
budding artists adam says the
exhibition's show that spain's young
people have hope for the future even
though half of spaniards under 25 are
unemployed people woke up to realize
that the situation now in many ways is
better than it was there may be less
money but money isn't really the
ultimate goal is just a vehicle and I
mean nobody remembers rich people and
it's one of the things people remember
culture they remember heritage and here
you've got an extraordinary wealth of
extraordinary wealth of that the roof
terrace on the other Palace Hotel in the
centre of Madrid offers a view across
the rooftops of the city in the evening
Adam soaks up the atmosphere of the
young art scene again this time at the
casado Santa Paul gallery he finds the
newcomers just as inspiring as history's
great artists maybe one day he'll be
reproducing one of their works
you
you